we should perhaps not be desperately
surprised with the line taken by mr
peskov in the sense that it is exactly
what vladimir putin has been saying what
their ambassador to the united nations
has been saying when presented with
evidence they simply hold up their hands
and say nothing to do with us
well
it's not true is it and and i think
they're very good at fake news and we
just need to
know that what we're saying is correct
we know we have journalists who are
disciplined and thoughtful and make sure
that they have clear sources and we just
have to carry on telling the truth but
more importantly gathering information
so that when the time comes we can take
out prosecutions against the relevant
people we must hold them to account for
the war crimes that they're obviously
committing and i mean the truth is is
that is that the evidence that we have
at the moment is just the tip of the
iceberg i fear you know because we're
only seeing it from the towns and
villages where the russians have
withdrawn there are many other towns and
villages where the russians are still in
occupation and we just don't know the
full extent of the horror in the in
those areas but just in terms of of
prosecuting war crimes and certainly
people wish to establish what what
actually has taken place in various
parts of the country but but given
russia's relationship or lack of
relationship with the icc how is it
possible you can have a special tribunal
basically that's what you can do and you
know we
where there's a will essentially i mean
remember people couldn't believe that we
would ever be able to hold the murderers
in yugoslavia to account and yet we did
in the end and we got most of the major
players you know stood trial rightly and
are now behind bars rightly
in terms of of what we have seen from
from nato in the past 24 hours there
feels like what there has been a there
has been an escalation nato has agreed
that they will be providing heavier
weaponry
are you entirely comfortable with that
given you know that the reason that we
have held off up until this point was
the suggestion that russia might declare
as a party to the war well
so i think what we've reached at the
moment is we've reached a stage whereby
the russians are to a certain extent
withdrawing but they're not
defeated you know they're regrouping
they're recalibrating and i fear they're
coming back
and what we need to do is use this
opportunity to regroup recalibrate
reorientate ourselves as well i think
some people hoped that we would be able
to that the war would be stopped fairly
quickly that we would stop the russians
in their tracks and this would be the
end of it and by now you know the
russians will be making their excuses
and leaving obviously that's not
happening so i think that what we need
to do and it is right that what we do is
we redouble our efforts now so if there
is anything left and there is on
sanctions we need to make sure that we
are really pushing you know we're going
the whole hog on that but also i think
we need to make sure that we are
supplying the weaponry that the
ukrainians clearly are asking for as
quickly as possible but just
specifically on on the way in which the
united kingdom has been helping yes
homes for ukraine scheme i think we've
got only perhaps as many as five or as
few i should say as 500 ukrainians um
welcomed here to the uk three weeks on
from the application process opening
understandably there are there are
logistical difficulties i think everyone
understands that and particularly in
getting a scheme up and running pretty
quickly but what would you be doing
differently right now first of all i
wouldn't be as generous as you've just
been because what i would say is this is
we knew for some time ahead of the
russians you know invading that it was
going to happen and what we've done in
other crises is that we've had
specialized schemes you know so focused
on like in hong kong or or you know
afghanistan we had special taylor
tailored schemes for dealing with the
refugees that were bound to come and
bound to be and we should have done the
same with ukraine but instead we had the
home office kind of putting their
fingers in their ears and saying la la
la la la you know and as people were
coming across the border they were still
resisting it but you will remember no
ukrainians being told you can pick fruit
if you want to come into the uk i mean
really insulting and we should have had
a proper scheme ready to go
and you know everything and although
slowly slowly they're getting into the
right place it's kind of such resistance
you know we had a time only a few weeks
ago when poor ukrainians were trailing
around europe trying to find a british
embassy in order to go into the right
place to fill in the paperwork now at
least it's online but it's still really
cumbersome so we really do need to have
a better system than this what we've
always said is that people should be
able to come here but once they're here
we need to make sure we have a record of
who they are and where they're going
particularly in order to make sure that
we safeguard the children can i ask you
about rishi sooner indeed about about
rishi sunak's partner and and i wonder
if do you have any sympathy for the
situation in which she finds herself in
i mean you are someone who you know has
been involved in criticism about the
wealth of your partner as well at some
point the situations are not parallel
because of course she has non-domiciled
status but i i just wonder whether or
not the kind of the private lives of
politicians partners
you might see that as perhaps being the
line is perhaps likely becoming blurred
in this story so first of all um just so
that there's no kind of misunderstanding
about this my husband's a judge um he uh
everybody knows that um he's been
knighted because he's a judge and
therefore i could call myself lady
newjie if i don't um it's a well-paid
job he's a public servant he pays all
his taxes um
if you are a minister in this country
you need to declare not just your own
financial interest but also that of your
spouse in order to make sure that there
are no conflicts of interest and it
seems to me that there is a clear
conflict of interest here because the
chancellor of the exchequer is
responsible for the rules on non-doms he
has a wife who has decided and she made
a positive decision to become a non-dom
which meant that she doesn't pay tax on
her worldwide income but only on her
income in the uk so is labour currently
advocating for non-dom status to be
removed
now what we're saying is that what she's
what what she's done is perfectly legal
but whether we think that it's fair
given that her husband is expecting so
many of us to be making so many
sacrifices he's increasing taxes 15
taxes he's increased he's expecting us
all to pay our to pull our weight but
not his partner but isn't it but isn't
he true then isn't he accurate then when
he says in the sun says to tahari ko
that the labour party is using his wife
to get to him i mean that that is what's
happening no because he should have
declared that his wife was a non-dom
because he's responsible for the rules
on non-doms so if there had been a
discussion in the treasury about i mean
let's say you look at the this
particular example or other examples of
non-doms and if you look at the details
it does seem a bit odd you know
sometimes you know i mean like she's
been here eight years she's got kids
she's living in downing street and her
taxpayers flat but she's not here as a
permanent resident i mean it does seem
odd you know so it may be that they may
have had discussions in the treasury
about updating these rules making sure
that they're more relevant would he been
involved in those discussions he
shouldn't have been and he should have
declared that he had a conflict of
interest but we don't know whether he
has or not because he hasn't abided by
the rules in declaring the in
you know his wife's financial position
but can can any chancellor then have a
partner with non-domiciled tax status do
you think
well i personally think there are
difficult times like this when we're
asking people to make as many sacrifices
as as they are it is a it is an odd
thing for a chancellor to be benefiting
from his partner taking full advantage
of the rules that are available there
for them to be able to avoid paying a
large amount of tax that seems to me to
be peculiar and as i say we don't know
to what extent his family household has
benefited from the decision that his
wife made um but you know it is also the
conflict of interest which is very
important we will see we will see what
further information may emerge from
number 11 at some point but just finally
on that on that topic
you will know how difficult it can be to
govern when number 10 downing street and
number 11 downing street do not get on i
think of back to the the tbgb's when
tony blair and gordon brown were were
literally at each other's throats if
reports are to be believed the prime
minister and the chancellor hate each
other's guts by the looks of things
right now how long is that sustainable
i think that there is a problem when we
have a a crisis like this a crisis in
terms of it's really affecting people's
day-to-day yeah and we need to have
proper leadership and we need to be able
to have a government that is making the
right decisions in order to help people
in the day-to-day and when you have two
men who are showboating and trying to
show off you know
against one another and fighting one
another then clearly that sort of
dysfunction means that then they're not
making any decisions really i don't
think i don't i think that they they
could have proactively done many things
in order to help with the with the
crisis but they haven't you know we have
said obviously that there should be a
windfall tax with the with the company
you know with it with the with the fuel
companies the energy companies they
don't seem to have been able to focus on
that i mean it's a really really good
idea and it would help you know every
family 600 pounds
well you know the
political parties have stolen good ideas
from each other since we were welcomed
and we would welcome it let them steal
it but they won't even do that emily
thornfield thanks for joining us